a magician and a lab that does far more
than just shine possibly Glennon worked
on this trick for a good four years
fine-tuning the sets the music and
staging it genuinely touches people and
affects them deep down you don't just
watch and think that was an amazing
magic trick it really touches and moves
you and evokes real emotions the
audience soon is charmed by the brazen
little lamp when 34 year old Patrick
Lennon is bringing objects to life he's
working at his day job as a programmer
in Cologne he built him wired his magic
lamp himself it took a lot of work it's
the Sun this is the diagram for the
internal wiring it's pretty complicated
the diagram alone took me a year to
complete and it's still working with
this trick for three years before I got
it to where I could perform with I took
you to the theater without knowing how
it would come across would people like
it was it only fantastic in my mind or
not then I got a standing ovation and
knew great it works under standing
ovations and dusty yeah I cut okay
[Music]
knowing how to juggle helped him learn
to perform magic tricks for both you
need extremely nimble fingers in 2006 he
saw some ingenious card tricks on the
internet and started imitating them
until he had them all down pat that's
when I caught the bug and I tried to
learn absolutely everything I could find
about card tricks not with the intention
of performing but just for myself for
the challenge and to pass the time Evans
missing home spoon in his search for new
card tricks he visited magic stores and
got to know other magicians and new
types of tricks
[Music]
can I start vigil no cash is king
okay no problem I'll pay cash as always
yes I love this was the first place
where I got to know fellow magicians and
heard about the magic circles okay then
I became a member now I'm on the
Executive Board in bond and enjoy it
very much he and fellow Magic Circle
members are currently busy organizing
bonds magicians festival the best
conjures from near and far cast their
spells in various categories my money
period soon
I worked on my manipulation act as it is
now for maybe five years that's
perfectly normal because it takes years
to learn the basics these moves are
instant this is a very typical move for
manipulators
[Music]
the large-scale
illusions require a team of assistants
and lots of space flick-flick modern
magic from Lando have won the German
championship twice so far with their
self built magic machines
but in cornerstone is timing therapy
timing is critical for a large-scale
illusion has to fit the music precisely
so everyone knows just what they have to
do it takes a lot of practice you have
to rehearse it over and over until
you've got it right
one favorite large-scale illusion is the
good old sawing a woman in half trick in
endless variations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there are so many incredibly good magic
acts and not only do they have the
magical element in common they also need
something special
sometimes it's the character that's so
fascinating that it makes you want to
watch it every time mister sometimes
it's a special effect that's so
astounding that you can't look away
and sometimes it's the story that's so
thrilling a story or Mathiason and
that's a good description of Patrick
linens magic lamp he's created his own
form of magical poetry and it's a
shining light in the mysterious world of
magic
[Applause]